en este vídeo vamos a usar un modelo
simple para el mercado de fondos
prestables para entender un fenómeno
conocido como efecto desplazamiento y
esto hace referencia a las veces que el
gobierno pide dinero prestado e invierte
y que en cierto punto podría desplazar
la inversión y los préstamos del sector
privado esto podría tener consecuencias
negativas para la economía probablemente
el resultado sería la disminución de
inversiones y podríamos tener menos
crecimiento de la economía entonces
vamos a ver cómo puede suceder el efecto
desplazamiento usando este mercado de
fondos prestables de modo que para tener
claro lo que pasa aquí el eje horizontal
es la cantidad de fondos prestables en
el eje vertical tenemos el precio de
pedir prestado que en este caso va a ser
nuestra tasa de interés real y nuestra
tasa de interés real de equilibrio y
cantidad de fondos de equilibrio está
determinada por la intersección de la
curva de oferta y la curva de demanda de
fondos prestables entonces qué pasa
vamos a escribir paso 1 el gobierno
decide
prestado para financiar parte de sus
gastos qué va a pasar con estas curvas
algunas de ellas va a cambiar claro que
sí si a cualquier tasa de interés dada
de repente tenemos un gran prestatario
que es el gobierno que ahora quiere
ingresar al mercado de fondos prestables
eso hará que la demanda de fondos
prestables se incremente entonces el
paso 1 que tenemos aquí hará que la
curva de demanda de fondos prestables se
mueva a la derecha así que aquí tenemos
el paso 1 y entonces nuestra nueva
demanda de fondos prestables se verá así
vamos a llamar la demanda de fondos
prestables prima de modo que esto va a
desplazar la curva de demanda de fondos
prestables de fp a la derecha y qué va a
pasar a raíz de esto bueno esto hará que
nuestra tasa de interés real aumente lo
podemos ver aquí en nuestro nuevo punto
de equilibrio se van a ofrecer más
fondos prestables aquí tenemos q prima y
podemos ver que esto ocurre a un costo
mayor es decir a una tasa de interés
real más alta
a esta la llamamos ere prima cuál es el
impacto en el sector privado de una tasa
de interés más alta imaginemos por un
segundo que esta curva azul es el sector
privado digamos que el gobierno empezó a
pedir préstamos y a cambiar la curva en
este vídeo si esta curva azul es solo el
sector privado con esta nueva tasa de
interés real el sector privado va a
pedir prestado mucho menos entonces
podemos decir que el sector privado pide
menos préstamos cuál va a ser el
resultado de esto bueno este es el
resultado negativo del efecto
desplazamiento como están pidiendo menos
préstamos entonces están invirtiendo
menos estamos teniendo menos capital
menos capital productivo que se usa para
producir bienes así que podemos decir
que tenemos menos acumulación de capital
que es otra manera de decir que la gente
está invirtiendo menos porque está
pidiendo menos préstamos hay menos
inversión en fábricas o en tecnología o
en alguna otra cosa que hace que las
personas sean más productivas entonces
si tenemos menos acumulación de capital
eso significa que tendremos un
crecimiento económico más lento una de
las formas en que un país realmente
empuja su curva de posibilidades de
producción o realmente empuja su curva
de oferta agregada de largo plazo hacia
la derecha y tiene un verdadero
crecimiento económico es a través de la
inversión pero si los costos de
endeudamiento son más altos tendrán
menos inversión menos acumulación de
capital y un crecimiento económico más
lento hasta el próximo vídeo